No, the father of the atomic bomb doesn't
pull off any heists inside dreams,
but there are some clear similarities
between "Oppenheimer" and "Inception."
Director Christopher Nolan himself says so.
Audiences are gearing up to see "Oppenheimer,"
Nolan's much-hyped summer 2023 release. But
in an interview with Wired, Nolan
himself seems to be looking to his
past a bit, particularly toward his
mind-bending 2010 film "Inception."
The final sequence from "Inception" is always
a fun discussion point among film enthusiasts.
The film's enigmatic closing moments inspire
multiple interpretations. Did Leonardo DiCaprio's
Cobb truly resurface from the dream world and find
his happily ever after with his kids? Or will the
dream totem continue spinning forever and signal
that he's really still submerged inside a dream?
"When you look at your totem, you know beyond a
doubt that you're not in someone else's dream."
Does Cobb even care after all he's
been through? Nolan told Wired,
"I mean, the end of 'Inception,' it's exactly
that. There is a nihilistic view of that ending,
right? But also, he's moved on and
is with his kids. The ambiguity is
not an emotional ambiguity. It's an
intellectual one for the audience."
The ending of "Oppenheimer" is less
ambiguous, but it's still an unsettling
finale. Nolan himself noted the similarities
to the conclusion of "Inception," saying,
"It's funny, I think there is an interesting
relationship between the endings of 'Inception'
and 'Oppenheimer' to be explored. 'Oppenheimer''s
got a complicated ending. Complicated feelings."
That complexity is often a trademark of Nolan's
work that threads together his vision from film
to film. Those who have seen "Oppenheimer" have
noticed it in his latest release, which is based
on the startling truths revealed in the book
"American Prometheus: The Triumph and Tragedy of
J. Robert Oppenheimer." It captures the harrowing
reality of the creation of the atomic bomb, two of
which were dropped on the Japanese cities Nagasaki
and Hiroshima by U.S. forces during World War II.
Nolan's film explores the ethical boundaries
crossed by the title character, who played a
pivotal role in bringing the weapon of mass
destruction to life. J. Robert Oppenheimer
was even dubbed "the father of the atomic bomb"
for his central involvement and research in the
initiative to build the a-bomb, the Manhattan
Project. Nolan told Wired of his new film,
"Some people leave the movie absolutely
devastated. They can't speak. I mean,
there's an element of fear that's there in
the history and there in the underpinnings.
But the love of the characters, the love of the
relationships, is as strong as I've ever done."
That strong character development would seem to
strengthen the comparison to "Inception,"
along with the fact that both films have
Cillian Murphy in the cast. He plays
the title character in "Oppenheimer."
Nolan took a complex, fascinating
approach to telling the story of
"Oppenheimer." Speaking with Total Film,
he shared that he set out to recall the
historical events depicted in the film
through J. Robert Oppenheimer's eyes,
making the otherwise straightforward
historical drama more personal. Nolan said,
"We're trying to tell the story of somebody's
life and their journey through personal
history and larger-scale history, and so the
subjectivity of the story is everything to me."
“In the case of this film, I wrote this script in
the first person. It’s the
only time I’ve done that.”
Nolan's character-centric view definitely
had an effect on Murphy. The director added,
"We want to view these events through
Oppenheimer's eyes. And that was the
challenge for Cillian that I set
him, to take us on this journey."
Nolan noted that Murphy's challenge
extended to pretty much the entire team
behind the movie. Every choice made had
to somehow circle back to Oppenheimer's
perspective on the world during such a
turbulent, yet pivotal point in history.
"Oppenheimer" opens on July 21.